Nigeria es un país famoso por su
Industria del cine
[Aplausos]
[Música]
habéis oído bien a estas alturas todos
sabéis que India y Estados Unidos son
los dos países que producen más
películas en el mundo Pues bien Nigeria
bien podría estar en el tercer puesto
solo en el año 2022 han producido más de
2.500 películas de hecho De igual forma
que hablamos de Hollywood o de Hollywood
bien podríamos hablar de Hollywood y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando tiene
nigeriano ni siquiera sabía que eso
existía Y sí tenéis razón hablamos de
películas de muy bajo presupuesto que
prácticamente sólo se consumen en África
pero esto es un buen ejemplo de todo el
potencial que tiene este país y lo poco
que lo conocemos nigeriano es un país
africano más es el país con la mayor
economía de toda África Hablamos de una
potencia petrolera en toda regla con
potencial de convertirse en una nueva
Rusia sin embargo estoy seguro de que
cuando todos pensáis en Nigeria la
primera imagen que os venga a la cabeza
sea ésta
[Música]
Exacto el país de pocos harán el país
donde llegaron a secuestrar a 276 niñas
en 2014 queridos amigos de visualpolitik
la Triste realidad es que Nigeria por
mucho potencial que tenga es hoy por hoy
un país miserable por muchos ingresos
que genera el petróleo el 40% de la
población vive en la pobreza absoluta
estamos hablando de más de 80 millones
de personas porque sí Nigeria también es
El séptimo país más poblado del mundo
tienen más de 206 millones de habitantes
pero no solo eso atentos a esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver el enorme potencial de
este país es el noveno país del mundo
que más ingresos obtiene por la
exportación del petróleo crudo y en el
ranking de países con reservas se lleva
el puesto un décimo justo detrás de los
Estados Unidos y aquí viene la gran
oportunidad de Nigeria la Unión Europea
necesita nuevos proveedores de petróleo
y Nigeria podría ser uno de los más
importantes Además este país tiene una
constitución y una estructura de estado
en teoría al menos democráticas algo que
la verdad no resulta nada común en
África Aunque es así lo que sí tienen en
común con otros países vecinos es la
corrupción la baja participación
electoral las limitadas libertades
civiles y unas instituciones débiles que
hacen que la democraciana sea
considerada muy frágil pero pese a todo
esto La pregunta es de verdad petróleo y
una mejora de su democracia sacar a los
nigerenos de la pobreza pueden ingerir
salvar Europa con su zumo de dinosaurio
podría incluso convertirse en una
especie de Rusia africana por supuesto
sin los problemas de la Rusia original
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
un país
250 etnias
[Música]
Nigeria es un país del que seguro que ya
habías oído hablar al fin y al cabo es
El séptimo país más poblado del mundo y
uno de los que más petróleo tiene Pero
qué es Nigeria exactamente pues veréis
Nigeria está habitada por
aproximadamente
250 grupos étnicos cada uno con sus
propias tradiciones y sus propias
lenguas causas hitbox yorubas y cientos
más se distribuyen por todo el
territorio Pues bien cuando llegaron a
este lugar los británicos y
establecieron un régimen colonial A
mediados del siglo XIX las asperezas
entre los grupos étnicos mayoritarios No
tardaron en producirse
de hecho los británicos dividieron esta
Colonia en tres regiones el norte de los
hausa y los fulani musulmanes el Este
que era de los igbo y el oeste de los
Yoruba que eran principalmente
cristianos y creéis que trataron estas
tres colonias por igual pues no para
nada el ojito derecho del imperio
británico en la Colonia era el norte
musulmán donde los emires ayudaban a las
fuerzas británicas a cambio de lujos en
fin lo típico El caso es que al final
los británicos optaron por otorgar la
independencia Nigeria en 1960 pero no
porque ellas se hubieran cansado de
ellos sino porque existían un montón de
grupos activistas presionando demasiado
hablamos por ejemplo de el grupo de
acción o el Consejo Nacional de Nigeria
y los camerunés sin embargo ya os
imaginaréis que un país creado a partir
de 250 etnias va a tener problemas
difícilmente se van a terminar
entendiendo políticamente y sabéis que
eso es exactamente lo que pasó y lo
cierto Es que tardó muy poco en suceder
porque seis años después de la
Independencia se dio el primer golpe de
estado desde entonces Nigeria quedó
sumida en el caos hasta seis golpes de
estado entre 1966 y 19 Y por supuesto
tensiones constantes entre el norte
islámico y el sur cristiano pero no sólo
eso también además de golpes de estado
hubo una guerra civil
en 1967 en la actual togo informaron del
asesinato de ciudadanos de la región
Norte de Nigeria en la región este los
ciudadanos del Norte Se volvieron tan
furiosos que empezaron a atacar y a
masacrar a los hijos que estaban en el
norte como Es lógico muchos de estos
igbos regresaron a su región de origen
la del este y en ese mismo año el
teniente coronel oyucu declaró la
independencia de la región
convirtiéndola en la República de biafra
Pues bien al principio parecía que
biafra tendría éxito Al fin y al cabo
era la región más rica en petróleo de
Nigeria pero su sueño independentista
fue con el tiempo convirtiéndose en una
verdadera pesadilla acabaron totalmente
rodeados y aislados lo que provocó una
hambruna que acabó con más de 30.000
vidas al día enfra entre ellas las de
mil niños insistimos cada día
el hambre es un arma de guerra y tenemos
toda la intención de usarla contra los
Rebeldes Allison Aida jefe de la
delegación nigeriana en los diálogos de
paz de niamey julio del 68 al final vía
frase rindió y volvió a formar parte de
Nigeria pero como podéis imaginar los
hitbox no se iban a olvidar nunca de ese
conflicto Sin embargo a pesar de todo
ello en 1999 la situación empezó a
cambiar después de la muerte del
dictador abacha que es cuando dio
comienzo la llamada cuarta República en
Nigeria
[Música]
Después de varias constituciones
fallidas y repúblicas dominadas por
completo por el ejército la cuarta
República parecía traer nuevas
esperanzas en ese mismo año se
celebraron nuevas elecciones y el hijo
del ex dictador o basanjo ganó y desde
entonces las sucesivas elecciones solo
ganaron los elegidos de ova sanjo todos
por supuesto del partido democrático
popular que es el principal partido del
país conservador y económicamente
liberal Eso sí siempre entre acusaciones
de fraude electoral y violencia política
sin embargo en 2015 Nigeria decidió dar
un golpe sobre la mesa atentos
elecciones en Nigeria muhammari gana la
presidencia Exacto mis queridos amigos
de visualpolitik en 2015 el pueblo
nigeriano de un volantazo a la izquierda
y eligió al social demócrata mujamado
bujari del partido de la oposición ahora
bien porque es esto una buena noticia
pues no no es porque nos guste
especialmente este político ni nada por
el estilo sino que en este caso y por
primera vez en la historia Nigeria Tuvo
una transición de poder pacífica es
decir que parece que por fin la
democracia puede llegar a funcionar en
este país Así que la pregunta es de
verdad esto es una tendencia que se va a
consolidar Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la Rusia de África
con los años Nigeria se ha convertido en
el principal país exportador de zumo de
dinosaurio en África De hecho entre 2015
y 2019 estaba produciendo más de 2
millones de barriles de crudo al día
para que os hagáis una idea Angola que
es su principal competidor en África
solo exportó 1,4 millones de barriles al
día en el año 2019 por eso podríamos
estar hablando de una auténtica Rusia
africana Nigeria ha mantenido sus
exportaciones a base de zumo de
dinosaurio desde el año 1977 cuando creó
su empresa Estatal Pero la realidad es
que el petróleo nigeriano empezó a
explotarse mucho antes
en 1937 cuando Nigeria era aún Colonia
británica Las empresas petrolíferas
británicas shell y bp empezaron a
explorar el territorio en busca de
petróleo en 1953 dieron con pequeñas
cantidades que todavía no podían
comerciar sin embargo en 1956 dieron con
su primera mina de oro negro viable
comercialmente estaba en la ciudad en El
delta del níger la zona más rica en
petróleo del país estas empresas sabían
que sus inversiones estaban totalmente
aseguradas por lo que decidieron empezar
también a refinar El crudo que estaban
extrayendo en 1965 construyeron la
primera refinería Y a partir de ahí
llegaron más empresas las americanas
Chevron y Texaco o la Italiana
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando vaya
caramelito para las empresas
petrolíferas verdad sin ninguna duda
solemos estar acostumbrados a ver que
los recursos energéticos están en manos
del Estado del país y exportador claro
estos son los modelos de Rusia o Arabia
Saudita por ejemplo pero en Nigeria es
mucho más flexible sí es cierto la
Constitución actual da al estado
nigeriano todo el control sobre sus
recursos naturales y energéticos Pero la
realidad es que nunca les ha temblado el
pulso a la hora de vender más derechos
de explotación por cheques bien jugosos
Por eso no nos extraña que Nigeria tenga
159 Campos petrolíferos y 1500 pozos de
extracción y desde luego muchos no son
del Estado gran parte pertenecen a
empresas extranjeras de hecho según el
gestor nigeriano de inversiones
petroleras el 98% de las reservas de
petróleo y activos operativos del sector
están en manos de seis petroleras
privadas occidentales entre ellas la más
relevante es shell pero no solo eso
entre cell exon Chevron ágil y Texaco
poseen hasta seis terminales de
exportación petrolífera además de varios
eructos pero no os equivo el gobierno
nigeriano no es tonto Nigeria no ha
dejado que las empresas extranjeras
tengan el control de toda la cadena de
producción la refinerías pertenecen al
Estado recordáis la refinería que
empezaron a construir shell y bp en 1965
Pues el estado la compró en 1978 y casi
todas las grandes refineras son
estatales El caso es que sin duda alguna
el petróleo se ha convertido en la mayor
exportación del país supone más del 70%
de todas sus ventas al exterior ahora
bien Qué significa todo esto si seguís
visualpolitik desde hace tiempo ya os
podéis imaginar por dónde van los tiros
Exacto corrupción
Nigeria está plagada de problemas en
torno al sector petrolífero nos
sorprenderá si os digo que una de las
mayores lacras de este país sea la
corrupción y no hablamos de cualquier
corrupción sino la del sector
petrolífero Y es que si el impacto de la
corrupción en Nigeria no fuera tan
grande ni te lo estaríamos contando pero
es que más del 20% del pib de este país
se va por el desagüe precisamente por
este motivo para que os hagáis una idea
solo con lo que pierde el país por culpa
de la corrupción se podría pagar toda su
deuda pública El problema es que tanto
políticos como empresarios sean
beneficiado de la corrupción en el
sector por ejemplo la exministra de
petróleo de Nigeria 10ani Allison
madueque fue condenada por permitir que
desaparecieran nada más y nada menos que
20.000 millones de dólares de la empresa
petrolífera Nacional de Nigeria incluso
la persona más rica del país y de África
al iko dan gote un empresario ha sido
acusado de comprar favores al ex
presidente obasanjo en el año 2003
la corrupción ha llevado a que los
ciudadanos nigerianos no vean Muchas
veces ni un dólar por la venta del crudo
de su país de hecho según el Banco
Mundial solamente un 1% de toda la
población de Nigeria se ha beneficiado
del sector petrolífero Esto no es solo
una mala noticia para los nigerianos
también lo es para las propias empresas
petroleras en muchas partes de Nigeria
las personas están empezando a
vandalizar los pozos y a robar el cru de
los combustibles de las ya cochambrosas
refinerías y oleoductos
por lo tanto no nos sorprende
encontrarnos noticias Como este la
refinerías petrolíferas ilegales de
Nigeria sucias peligrosas lucrativas en
muchas ciudades y pueblos como en los
del delta del níger los ciudadanos se
dedican a robar crudo y vandalizar las
instalaciones petrolíferas para muchos
de ellos esta es la única forma de salir
adelante en un país con una tasa de
desempleo del 33% y de desempleo juvenil
del 54%, por lo tanto la corrupción ha
llevado a que en todo el sur del país
muchas comunidades se dediquen a robar
crudo y a refinarlo ellos mismos Pero
ojalá este fuera El único problema
atentos
[Música]
un estado fallido
recordáis biafra el territorio que se
intentó independizar en 1967 de Nigeria
Pues bien cuando os decíamos antes que
los signos no habían olvidado lo que
sucedió durante la Guerra Civil nos
referíamos a que hoy muchos de ellos
siguen al pie del cañón de hecho los
secesionistas ivos tienen su propio
movimiento militante este grupo se
encuentra hoy en la lista negra de
grupos terroristas para Nigeria sabéis
Por qué Pues porque ellos también roban
El crudo y sabotean las refinerías tener
en cuenta que entre ellos y el resto de
grupos organizados que también roban
crudo han hecho que el estado nigeriano
pierda millones de dólares algunas
estimaciones señalan que desde el año
2008 las pérdidas por los robos los
sabotajes y la caída de la producción
resultante pueden alcanzar los 100.000
millones de dólares vamos que Es lógico
que los dirigentes del país y Los
inversores Internacionales estén
preocupados pero ojo porque este no es
ni muchísimo menos el único grupo
terrorista del país de hecho tampoco es
el más sanguinario a decir verdad el más
temido de todos los grupos terroristas
ha sido y es uno que muchos de vosotros
estoy seguro ya conocéis boco harán
nació en 1995 como un grupo juvenil
musulmán no violento sin embargo con el
paso de los años al considerar que la
deriva de Nigeria era totalmente
contraria a los deseos de ala comenzó su
Cruzada para convertir al país en un
estado islámico Regido por las haría y
para lograrlo en 2002 empezaron a
adoptar formas violentas su primer
objetivo fue la ciudad de maiduguri y su
expansión comenzó hacia el resto del
país especialmente el noreste de Nigeria
no obstante no fue hasta el 2009 cuando
comenzaron a ganar la fuerza que les
convirtió en el grupo terrorista más
temido del país y en uno de los más
sanguinarios de toda la región del
sahell su narrativa apela a los sectores
más desfavorecidos del país Así es como
han llegado a reclutar a más de 40.000
combatientes
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque no es el
único grupo terrorista que a sola
Nigeria fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
además de los problemas con poco jaram o
el movimiento secesionista de diáfra el
gobierno nigeriano tiene otros frentes
abiertos ya sea el de las bandas en el
Noroeste del país o el secesionismo
Yoruba en el sur como el de villafra o
el conflicto entre pastores musulmanes y
agricultores cristianos que atraviesa
todo el país entonces podríamos decir
que Nigeria es un estado fallido la
mayoría de analistas no tienen duda Sí
lo es el Gobierno nigeriano no tiene el
control de la zona dominada por boca
harán Tampoco puede intervenir en el
conflicto entre pastores y agricultores
en este caso hablamos de un conflicto
que ha acabado con la vida de más de
20.000 personas desde 1999 no obstante
hay otros que no se fijan tanto en el
control del estado en todo su territorio
soberano por eso también hemos escuchado
analistas que prefieren decir que no es
un estado fallido sino que es un estado
que está fallando que no es lo mismo es
más estos dicen que Nigeria puede
empezar a funcionar por tres razones hay
ahora una mayor estabilidad política
mayor tolerancia entre grupos étnicos y
hay una identidad nacional nigeriana más
fuerte pero la realidad es que a día de
hoy el gobierno de Nigeria no puede
controlar todo su territorio dicho de
otra forma a es un estado fallido sin
embargo las cosas pueden cambiar la
Guerra de Ucrania ha supuesto una
ventana de oportunidad para este país y
diréis que tiene que ver lo que pasa en
Ucrania con Nigeria pues atentos a esta
noticia Rusia prohibirá la venta de
petróleo con topes de precio según el
kremlin Moscú está dispuesto a reducir
la producción para compensar la pérdida
de exportaciones según el vicepresivo
Primer Ministro Alexander Novak Rusia ya
ha comunicado que no va a dar más
petróleo en la Unión Europea si se le
pone un precio límite esto significa una
cosa Europa necesitan nuevos proveedores
de zumo de dinosaurio esta podría ser la
oportunidad de Nigeria de empezar a
cambiar las cosas además El crudo
nigeriano tiene una calidad muy similar
al de área Saudita es decir hablamos de
la mejor calidad fácil de refinar y
relativamente barato de extraer Nigeria
puede empezar a hacer que sus pozos
trabajen sin descanso sin embargo hay
varios problemas que pueden romper este
sueño
[Música]
el principal es que su producción de
diarios depende de lo que diga la OPEP
Plus y teniendo en cuenta la tendencia
que llevan últimamente van a seguir
reduciendo su producción para alzar más
los precios además la inmensa corrupción
en el país va a seguir haciendo que este
sueño sea imposible Cuanto más dinero se
robe y menos llegue a los ciudadanos más
robos y sabotajes tendrán En otras
palabras menos dinero es una especie de
círculo vicioso Y por último la
refinerías y algunos se encuentran en
pésimas condiciones los fondos del
gobierno pasan por tantísima burocracia
que el mantenimiento de las
instalaciones petrolíferas muchas veces
es prácticamente nulo y claro cuanto
peor están las infraestructuras menores
la producción Nigeria ha dado el primer
paso para solucionar estos problemas
consiguiendo cierta estabilidad
democrática pero habrá que ver lo que
sucede en las próximas elecciones que
por cierto son este año 2023 porque
Sabiendo la historia de Nigeria no nos
extrañaría que hubiera otro golpe de
estado Así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros conseguirá Nigeria acabar con
la corrupción y el terrorismo llegará a
convertirse en la nueva Rusia en este
caso para bien para la Unión Europea
logrará mejorar las condiciones de vida
de sus ciudadanos podéis vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]